il n'y avait pas de tempête pour
empêcher la rencontre et le ciel semble
même s'éclaircir dans les relations
entre Québec et Ottawa
d'abord pour la première fois depuis 2
ans François Legault se dit confiant
sujet des transferts en santé plus
optimiste après la rencontre qu'avant la
rencontre je comprends qu'il veut pas un
échec bon déjà il était mis sur la table
de partager les données qui sont déjà
publiques j'aime mieux ça que d'entendre
parler de conditions est-ce que vraiment
on entrevue de fin d'année avec patrice
Roy juste un Trudeau lui parle de
transparence plutôt que de conditions et
évoque même une entente avant le dépôt
du budget fédéral très bientôt on
l'espère c'est quoi ça très bientôt
la situation du chemin Roxane là aussi
les discussions semblent avoir été
constructives juste être Rudo parle
d'une entente avec les États-Unis pour
mieux contrôler la frontière
François Lego ce sont moins seul
pour qu'une partie de ces
arrivants soient transférés d'autres
provinces mais les deux premiers
ministres n'arrivent toujours pas à
s'entendre sur la façon de freiner le
déclin du français à Montréal Québec
veut appliquer sa Charte de la langue
française
Ottawa sa réforme de la Loi sur les
langues officielles
d'avoir un signal clair que la langue de
travail doit être le français dans
toutes les entreprises pour fédérales on
respecte les champs de compétences et
les champs de compétences qui disent que
les bancs c'est de compétences fédérales
je veux pas que il doit provinciale
régit des institutions fédérales pas
plus que monsieur Legault voudrait que
je m'immense dans un centre commercial
si la relation entre les deux premiers
ministres s'adoucissent aussi parce que
les prochaines élections sont sur la
scène provinciale que fédérale semble
bien loin et à ce sujet l'arrivée de
Pierre poilière motive Justin Trudeau à
demeurer en poste pour en découdre avec
le chef conservateur lors du prochain
scrutin et vraiment envie oui ça me
tente merci
pour prendre sa place devront donc
patienter encore un moment ici Valérie
Gamache Radio-Canada
Ottawa